The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: OK, so what
I'm going to try to do today
is kind of a fun case
study on spatial modeling.
And then we will
have time afterwards,
especially with the
Singapore folks,
to try to at least
have brief meetings
on a couple of the projects.
I've met with at
least one group.
I think one group you
guys met with Dave Hardt.
At least talked, email.
Did you meet also?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: OK.
Because it looked like you guys
are in good shape to, right?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
DUANE BONING: He said do more.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: OK.
So we can have some
follow up on that as well.
But what I'm going to do is
go through this case study.
My preferences
actually this is--
I would have liked to
have been able to talk
about this a little bit earlier,
because this is some very
neat stuff on spatial
modeling that in the past
has sometimes been a
part of some projects.
So maybe you can
look at this and see
if there's something extra on
spatial modeling you can do.
Essentially, this is going to
be based on three papers that
are also on the website.
There's a paper by
Davis, one by Mozumder,
and one by Guo and Sachs.
So you can grab those
papers and learn more.
But my basic agenda
is as shown here.
First I want to sort of talk
a little bit about applying
the same response surface
modeling and regression
methodology that
we've talked about
for things like
process conditions
also to spatial parameters.
So if you were
spatially sampling,
could you build a model as a
function of spatial coordinates
and get a sense of spatial
uniformity across a wafer,
across a part, across
some spatial dimension?
And of course,
the answer is yes.
What's interesting is then when
you go and calculate things
like uniformity or
uniformity metrics,
there's some special
issues that come up.
And in particular,
your sampling plan
can affect dramatically what
number you get for uniformity.
And so we'll talk about ways
to not fool yourself on that.
The second part will be
then to go back and say, OK,
if I can do a response surface
model on spatial coordinates
and the process is changing,
how do I put those two things
together to model
spatial variation
as a function of the process?
And there's two
different ideas, sort
of opposite cuts at the
same problem, one based
on the Mozumder paper and
the other by Guo and Sachs
that I think are a
very interesting case
study in that they show an
evolution in the thinking
about how to efficiently
and effectively do that.
So let me talk first about
just purely spatial modeling.
And of course, we
know that there
can be a spatial
trend, systematic trend
in many, many processes.
Most of the methods we've
been talking about so far kind
of we're looking at
random variation, ways
of assessing as if
we were sampling
from a Gaussian or
some other process.
But underlying that, you may
have that noise, measurement
noise, or whatever,
but underlying that,
there may be a
systematic spatial trend.
And these may result from
inherent equipment or process
asymmetries, be
highly repeatable.
You would like to be able
to capture and express them.
So I've sort of
pictured here an example
where you might have a
concave or convex shape.
If I were measuring some
parameter across the wafer,
like a film thickness,
other geometric parameters,
or some material property
like film resistivity.
And very often
maybe gas flows are
a little bit different in the
center of the wafer and so on.
You get these sort of
bowl shaped patterns.
But there may be other
kinds of spatial patterns,
and you'd like to be
able to capture that.
So our goal is how
do we model that?
And then how do
we boil that down
into an overall metric that says
how good this is and then drive
the process to try
to improve that?
Decrease non-uniformity,
improve uniformity.
So what I'm going to
do is show an example.
And what I'm going to do
here is use synthetic data.
By the way, what I mean
by synthetic data is
I'm going to generate data
that I know it's properties of.
I am going to
generate a data with
a known statistical and
systematic, a known random
and a known systematic
component to it.
This is a useful
technique that you
might consider somewhere in one
of your team projects as well.
You may be dealing
with real data.
And very often you don't
know what ground truth is.
And that's the whole interesting
thing about a project
is you don't really
know the truth.
What we're trying to do
is infer things about it
from experimental data.
If you're also exploring
some methodology,
you want to see does this new
methodology that I've come up
with that I think
solves some problem
or applies to some
aspect of this problem?
You can also test that
with synthetic data
that you generate yourself.
And it's a nice complement in
some cases to the other project
data that you're doing.
So the data that I'm generating
has a systematic component
that is a circular or
elliptic kind of wafer map.
Plus it's got some superimposed
random noise on it.
And what I'm going
to do is sample it
in two different ways.
So I'm going to generate
two sampled data sets off
of a more basic data
set that I create.
And the sampling
patterns are going
to be two that are commonly used
in semiconductor manufacturing.
One is a circular wafer map.
Let's see.
Do I have a picture of it?
Yeah.
So here's a radial or
circular sampling plan.
The basic idea that I take
a point at the center,
then I take points
around some radius,
I take additional points
around another radius,
and I take additional
points at a third radius
so that I've got these
rings of concentric circles
as a sampling plan.
An alternative one
is to simply use
a rectangular or
square sampling plan.
So those are going to be two
different sampling plans.
What you would hope is you
get the same uniformity
metric off of the
two, that it shouldn't
be sensitive to sampling.
I'm going to show you, in fact,
that it can be quite sensitive.
OK, so what's my synthetic data?
It's shown here.
This is in fact the
elliptic component,
the systematic component,
that I create some output.
Call it resistivity here
just to be concrete.
Plus random Gaussian
0 mean noise.
So I've got, say, some
measurement noise,
process noise
superimposed on this.
What I'm going to try
to do is two things.
One is build a
response surface model.
Maybe, hopefully,
recover something close
to the underlying ground
truth that I've imposed here.
And we can now assess how
good a response surface model
fit is, because I know
what the truth is.
Second, I'm also
going to calculate
a non-uniformity metric.
And the basic metric is
going to be something
like a noise to signal ratio.
That is to say, the
normalized standard deviation
across my measurement points.
So I calculate the mean.
I calculate the standard
deviation, normalize or divide.
So I'm getting
something, if I multiply
by 100, something like a
percentage non-uniformity
across this wafer.
Here's the data,
just so you have it.
What I get in this sampling
plan is 25 total data points,
one at the center and then
eight at each of 25, 50,
and 75 millimeters
away from the center.
This is assuming sort of a 200
millimeter wafer, if you will.
And here's the actual data based
on my underlying synthetic data
model.
Here's the square sampling plan.
In this case, you'll
notice that a few
of the points,
these corner points,
actually fall off the
edge of a round wafer.
So they are discarded.
And those are the
ones in bold here.
Those ones are removed,
because they're
outside of the wafer boundary.
That should be a plus minus.
So this actually has, in fact,
slightly fewer data points.
It has only 21 data points,
whereas the previous sampling
plan actually has more data.
It's 25.
Yeah.
3 times 8 plus 1.
25 data points.
OK.
One thing I want to--
I'll be showing some jump plots,
some surface plots, contours,
and so on.
And the contouring does show
a little bit of difference
because it interpolates
just to plot things.
But in both of these
cases, they pretty much
look similar except
for some adjustment
because of the location
of the data points.
And if anything,
the radial 25 points
looks like it actually kind of
interpolates a little bit more
to the roundish or
elliptic underlying pattern
that I said I was imposing.
This one because
of the square grid
looks like it may
have some artifacts.
But that gives you a
feel for what's going on.
What we've got is a
not quite center high.
It's not a pure bowl
right in the center.
It's a little bit off
center, and it's not
perfectly circular.
It's kind of elliptic.
So that gives you a feel for
what the underlying pattern is.
So I say I want to fit a model.
I'm going to fit a generic
second order model in x and y.
So it's got linear coefficients
in x and y, an interaction
term, and second order terms,
x squared and y squared.
So six total coefficients.
What I'm doing first here
is the radial pattern
where I had 25 data points.
And you can sort of
see what happens here.
What we've got is
an r squared that
looks like it's about 0.65.
Doesn't sound great, but I know
there's noise in the process.
So I got to look at
it in a little bit
more detail at the ANOVA and
see is my model significant.
The r squared is make
me a little bit worried.
It's not great.
But I look, and overall the
model compared to the error
terms is significant.
So I've got an f that
is much, much larger
than I would expect
by chance alone.
It's 99.94% significant.
OK, great.
So I've got a model that is
capturing something going on.
Then I can go in and look
at the parameter estimates,
look at each of the individual
terms, look at the t ratio,
and look at the probability
of those being significant.
And they all look
pretty significant
except this one
for sure, a y term.
It says no, 0.5
chance that would
have occurred by chance alone.
And I've only got maybe
92 %or 91% chance or level
of confidence in this xy term.
But if I was looking
at, say, 95% confidence
interval cutoffs, I
might reject that term.
And we'll see later,
that's correctly rejecting
that term if you look back.
So knowing ground
truth, actually this
raises already a worry.
How come on correctly
rejecting the xy term
but incorrectly
rejecting another term?
Interesting.
OK.
Let's look at the other case.
I'm using a rectangular
pattern fitting
the same model in this case.
What happens now?
Well, now we only
have 21 data points.
Notice that the r squared
appears to be better.
That's interesting.
Again, the model is
highly significant.
And now if I look at
the individual terms,
the x is significant,
the y is significant,
the xy is not significant.
That's rejected.
The x squared and
the y squared look--
I guess the y squared is kind
of right marginal right at about
95%.
So it seems like it's coming
up with different terms
in the model.
And also we'll see in a
second when I compare them,
it's coming up with some
different estimates.
So maybe this isn't a surprise.
The sampling plan is affecting
the model that I'm building.
Doesn't sound too bad so far.
But what I also want to do--
let me compare them first.
And then what I
want to do is also
calculate a uniformity metric
across all of this data
and see what happens.
So here's our truth.
I've expanded out
that original model
of the systematic
component contaminated
by noise out to the x terms,
the xy, and the x squared terms.
And here is the radial sampling
plan and the square sampling
plan.
And the coefficients,
some of them
are not radically different.
They're kind of in the ballpark.
But in terms of deciding
which terms are kept
and which are rejected, we
know that this one, in fact,
really is 0, whereas this
one tries to keep it.
This one is very much smaller,
and we actually get rid of it.
This one's small and this
one's small but real.
Both of the models
fit parameters for it
but make different cutoff
points on what's significant
and what's not.
Now, what's really
interesting, I think,
is I now take that same data
and I go back-- ah, great.
Come on in, Charlene.
What?
AUDIENCE: She's
setting up right now.
DUANE BONING: Oh, Charlene,
you can set up in here.
Thank you.
Is if I take those
two sampling plans
and I look back at the mean
and the standard deviation
just across my sampling
points and calculate
that non-uniformity metric.
In one case, it's
about a factor of two
different than the other.
The question is why?
And you can ponder that
question as you get coffee,
because that's what
I'm going to do.
So now I think
everybody's had a chance
to ruminate on this
question of non-uniformities
or at least read the next
two sub-bullets at the bottom
of the page, and then
everybody has a good idea
of what might be going on.
One is, of course, we've
got systematic curvature.
I'm not random sampling,
so I may, in fact,
hit different points
on that curvature.
So that's one hypothesis
is just because
of the particular places where
my points happened to fall,
that's one idea.
What we'll find out, and I'll
show that by more densely
sampling, that's actually not
what's going on necessarily
in this problem.
Actually, it's the structure
of the sampling plan.
And underlying that is how much
data or what spatial region
is each data point representing
of the underlying wafer
surface.
So let me try to explain that.
So what I've done here is gone
back and tried to say maybe
I just wasn't sampling enough
with just 25 or 21 data points.
What's my best guess at
the true non-uniformity?
Which one of these
two should I believe?
Which one is closer,
the 1.9%, the 3.2%?
What's a better sampling plan?
Actually, before I go into
that, what do you think?
I need a vote here.
How many people think
that the radial sampling
plan is probably closer
to the truth in terms
of both the model,
but more importantly,
the non-uniformity
number that comes out?
And how many people think it's
a rectangular sampling plan?
So all those think the
radial sampling plan is going
to be better, raise your hand.
I got I got two here
and a half. three.
We got two, three, three in
Singapore, four in Singapore.
Oh, we're talking it up.
We're talking it up.
OK, how about the
rectangular sampling plan?
About evenly divided.
I got three here,
one in Singapore.
And OK, that must leave four
asleep people who didn't vote,
something like that.
OK.
What I'm going to try to
do is get a close estimate
to what maybe better truth is.
And the way I'm
going to do that is
try to take a very dense spatial
sample so that hopefully it's
not just sort of the
random location of points.
I'm going to kind of get
really close to almost
a full representation
of the surface.
And this is almost a 900 point--
slightly under 900 point sample.
What is it?
665, I guess.
A 29 by 29 spatial
sample and then the
points that fall within
the radius of the wafer.
And as you do that, you
actually get a, quote,
a "true non-uniformity"
that's about 3%
closer to the other number.
And if one does a response
surface model fit,
there's a couple of important
points to come up with this.
I go in and I fit the model.
In this case, the coefficients
that come out of the model
are actually quite close to
the true systematic piece.
But notice that the r squared
is still only about 0.77,
something like that.
Why is the r squared so bad?
I got tons of data.
And the answer is kind of
highlighted right here.
I've still got lots of
random noise in the process.
I was adding magnitude variance
0.49 or 0.7 standard deviation
values to all of
my measurements.
I cannot model the random noise.
That's my residual
that's leftover.
I could include it as an
estimate of the random noise
and know what that is,
but I can't pull that
into the systematic model.
So there's always a ground if
there's noise and randomness
that you can never capture.
OK, so this seems
to be suggesting
that maybe that square
sample with the smaller
number of points was
a little bit better.
What's going on?
This finally gets me
to the Davis paper.
And what they're
going to propose
is a method for looking
at systematic trends.
They're first going
to make the point
that the signal to noise ratio,
this standard deviation over mu
or mu over standard
deviation, if I turn it
into a signal to noise, is
sensitive to both the location
and the number of measurements.
And they're going to propose
a difference statistic rather
than just the sample
standard deviation
to try to get at what
a better, truer measure
of overall
non-uniformity will be.
Turns out this
integration statistic
is based on fitting of
splines to your data,
and not a lot of
people go in for that.
What I'm going to show is that a
relatively simple approximation
achieves a lot of the
goals of this integration
statistic, which is worrying
about uniform sampling
spatially, or
alternatively, by weighting
the importance of each of
your measurement points
by the amount of area
that it's representing.
So that's the core
of the problem.
So what Davis does is looks at,
first off, a sort of a smaller
radial kind of picture
compared to the one I showed.
It's only got 13 data points.
Here's the 13 data points
with just linear interpolation
between them.
So that's the surface
example that he's using.
And if you just purely linearly
interpolate between them,
you can see that's a
pretty coarse approximation
to that surface.
One can easily be worried that
you might get bias or variance
errors in trying to calculate
with just those data points.
What they're proposing is using
thin plate splines, these TPS
methods, which are conceptually,
basically fitting localized
polynomials such that you have
minimum curvature over the data
points or knots in the data.
All right.
I'm sure there are statistical
packages and others that
can help fit those
thin plate splines.
I found when I've
tried this it's
very tricky, because what
localized means can be a little
bit tricky.
You've got other kind
of human intervention
going on in trying
to fit these things.
So it can be a
little bit tricky.
But essentially,
what they're after is
trying to get a model
for the whole surface.
And then once they
have the whole surface,
then calculate an
overall metric as
if I had an infinite number of
measurement points representing
the whole surface.
So I want an integrated measure,
an integrated statistic i,
that captures the
total deviation
from a target or total deviation
from some nominal value.
And so what they're
doing here is calculating
a normalized
integral of deviation
of this interpolated surface,
gr is their thin plate spline,
from some target value,
and then just integrating
that over the surface.
Total deviation
from some target.
Presumably the target
would be just one value.
I guess you could extend
to whatever target
spatial distribution you wanted.
And then they're normalizing
it by the total volume
of the surface.
So it's sort of like a
standard deviation over mu
except what it is is total
deviation over total volume.
Now, this is just
total deviation.
And if I was just
summing up deviations
as a measure of variation just
in some randomly sampled data
set not having to
do with space, you
might be worried about that.
Why would you be worried
about just summing up
total deviations?
Positive deviations, negative
deviations, they'd cancel out.
So if I was plus and minus
huge amounts but about
the same amount
plus and minus, I
might fool myself and think they
might cancel out and come to 0.
And I'd say, oh,
everything's great.
And they're really
completely different.
And that's why we
often use things
like squares or
absolute value to try
to account for or penalize for
both plus and minus deviations.
And so in the Davis
paper, one can
go in and apply some other
generalized loss transformation
to that deviation.
So you can do a sum
of squared deviations
that looks a lot more
like a standard deviation.
But again, the idea here
is they want to integrate
that over the whole surface.
Represent all of the surface,
not just the few data
points that you had,
but do that using
the interpolated function.
Now, there's an approximation
to this integral
that they mention, which is if
I have my lost transformation,
I have my actual data points.
So these are my
measured data points.
And I have the deviation
of that measured point
and then my h might be the
square or the absolute value.
If I simply sum those
for my data points,
I get something close,
again, to standard deviation,
a sum of squares.
But there's one big difference.
And that's right here.
The c sub j.
And essentially the
c sub j is a weight
that corresponds to if I was
doing the spatial integration,
I would be integrating over
these thin little patches
around each of my
measurement points.
It wouldn't be just
that measurement point.
It would be representing the
surface near that measurement
point.
And the c sub j is
a weight that says,
how much area on my surface
does that measurement point
represent?
How much vote does
that one point have?
And that can be very different
in these two sampling plans.
So what's neat is that if you
weight appropriately for area
that the point
represents, you actually
get fairly close to something
like the integration coming
from a thin plate spline.
OK.
So there's a couple of
plots in Davis's paper
where they're taking that
typical radial sampling
pattern.
Here's a perfectly circularly
symmetric pattern, 15%
systematic variation, 2%
random superimposed on it.
And then what they're
doing is looking at an SNR.
This is basically just sigma
over mu of just the data
points.
And they're showing
what estimates
over 300 different
runs of this model
with different amounts
of noise each time,
just different instantiations
of the random 2% noise, what
do they calculate
for sigma over mu?
So each time they do
300 runs, out here
they do it taking 73
different measurements
around the wafer with a
typical radial spatial pattern.
This is the problematic
one we saw earlier.
And notice there is a
spread, as you would expect,
because the noise is in there.
But look what happens
as you go to smaller
numbers of measurements.
First off, the spread
or the variance
in your estimate of
sigma over mu increases.
That makes sense, right?
I have less data.
I'm going to have more
variance in how I'm
estimating standard deviation.
We already know that estimating
standard deviation in general
requires a lot of data.
It's really a tough thing.
So it's getting worse.
But even worse than that,
especially for, say,
five measurements or
even 13 measurements,
a little bit there, is
the average value coming
from repeated evaluations is
not equal to the true underlying
average?
In other words, there's bias.
The estimator of sigma
over mu is biased.
It's not a very good estimator.
And as you have smaller
numbers of parameters,
that unequal weighting
of the surface
is biasing or fooling you.
Even on average you're going
to on average be wrong.
What they're showing
is if they actually
do their whole thin plate
spline I stat statistic,
they argue both the variance is
smaller, but more importantly
is it's unbiased.
Even when you get down to
small numbers of measurements,
you're at least
on average right.
And that's just these two plots
that are simply boiled down
into this comparison
that shows as a function
of the number of measurements
how good the statistic is.
So the spread of the statistic
over the mean of the statistic.
And showing that the
variance of the statistic
itself is getting smaller with
the integration statistic.
So you're basically
doing a better job
of estimating with their
proposed integration statistic.
Now, it's not perfect.
And in fact,
conceptually, if I only
have a small number
of sampling points,
I can still be prone to where
those sampling points happen
to lie if I have
a complex surface.
And so they're also showing
an asymmetric underlying
non-uniformity, this crazy shape
down here in the lower left.
And imagine I'm only sampling
with five data points.
Well, if those five data
points land in one orientation
or if they land then
slightly offset in angle,
I am spatially sampling
different parts
of that surface.
So what happens then?
And what they basically
show is, yes, their I stat
does have some sensitivity.
But because you're
trying to interpolate
the rest of the surface,
you do a better job.
You're not completely dependent
just on that local measurement
point.
Both approaches are still
highly sensitive to angle,
but the pure sigma over
mu is much more sensitive.
You get about 20% smaller
variation with their I stat.
OK.
So what are the key
lessons out of this part
of the case so far, this paper?
I think the key
lessons are watch out
for your sampling plan.
And especially if any of you go
into the semiconductor industry
or I guess any industry
dealing with round substrates,
be careful, because you will
run into this circular sampling
plan again and again.
And if you're calculating
some metric that is equally
weighting each of these points
where each of these points is,
in fact, points off on
the edge of the wafer
are representing a bigger area.
But they're equally weighted
with smaller sampling points
near the center of the wafer.
And this is a problem that I've
seen come up again and again
and again that people,
I think, are not
as aware of as they ought
to be in the industry.
It's easy to fix.
One fix that I recommend,
that I think is the cleanest,
is simply do a more
uniform sampling.
That rectangular sampling
has a great benefit.
How much area does
each point represent?
An equal area.
It's not dependent on an r
theta kind of calculation.
Second is if you do have some
non-uniform spatially sampling
plan, you can kind of fix it
by doing a weighted metric
or a weighted regression.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Normally, you
have a different kind
of sampling plan like that for,
say, the [INAUDIBLE] terms.
But it would be four
ranges of the [INAUDIBLE]
and four ranges of the wafer.
And then we would
applicate hundreds of times
over the wafer.
So in that case, does that
factor then, because you're--
DUANE BONING: So Nalish's
point is often, say,
if you're sampling
within each chip,
so here's our big wafer with
lots and lots of these chips,
you might sample
spatially the same ring
oscillator in different
corners of the chip
and then-- since there
are multiple chips.
I think, again, you've got to
be a little bit alert to what
it is you're doing
with that data
and how you're calculating it.
But that chip by chip
kind of sampling plan
has the advantage that chips
are generally rectangular.
And so maybe by
accident or by free,
you're usually getting a more
equally representative sampling
plan that lets you fit
or calculate metrics
a little bit more fairly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
had mentioned the sensitivity
to the amount of area cover.
But a lot of times you have
more of a sensitivity to factor,
depending on if SRAM is nearby
or a populated logic is nearby.
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So this is kind of good
for wafer level modeling.
Nalish is also pointing
out in many cases,
maybe this is an SRAM and
this is logic over here,
and you're sensitive
to other, what
I would call, finer
grained systematic sources
of variation, like
layout pattern density,
proximity to other structures,
other perturbing effects.
And those are extremely
interesting and fascinating
to look at.
And I think the
basic strategy is
if you know what
those are as factors
and can represent
them as factors,
you can actually do some
of the kind of ANOVA
and model fitting with
those as factors in addition
to or separating from
spatial xy dependencies.
So it's usually better if you
know what those factors are not
just trying to let x and
y be the stand in for them
but actually explicitly
include those things
so you know what causes what.
And that's a very
interesting area.
Any other questions on
this spatial sampling?
I think it's kind of cool
but relatively intuitive
once you think about it.
So the next thing I want
to do is say, OK, now I
know how to be careful in
building a spatial response
surface model.
But what if I'm worried
about how that surface
changes as a function
of process conditions.
What I'd like to do is have
both process and spatial
dependencies in it.
I'm going to show first
off an approach that
basically builds a two layered
response surface model.
This is the Mozumder
and Loewenstein paper.
And then I'll come
back to it and flip it
around that says
in the first case,
the first approach is basically
to build the model of space
and then take each
of the coefficients
in your spatial model,
your a3 times the xy term,
and now model that a3 term
as a function of your process
conditions.
Got it?
The second approach
does the opposite.
It says, I'm going to build a
model of this particular site
location as a function
of process conditions.
And then I can fit a spatial
model once I have that.
So it's two completely
separate or orthogonal ways
of looking at the problem.
So the first one here is "Model
for Semiconductor Process
Optimization Using Functional
Representations of Spatial
Variations in Selectivity."
And they make some of the
same kinds of observations
that we've talked about.
But what they're
doing is basically
trying to say, OK, I have to
be careful in how I calculate
my non-uniformity metric, but I
want to calculate that and then
understand how that
changes as the function
of different process conditions.
And in particular,
they're looking
at a silicon nitride
wet etch looking--
or silicon nitride
plasma etch, excuse me.
And looking at things like
the etch traits of the silicon
nitride, etch rates
of the silicon dioxide
as a function of things like
gas flows process conditions.
Now, they're actually worried
about two key parameters
or three key parameters.
One is the etch rate.
Faster rates are better.
Uniformity is better.
But they also worry
about the relative etch
rate between nitride and oxide
and they want high selectivity.
They want to be able to
etch through the oxide
but stop on the underlying
nitride or vice versa, I guess.
This is a nitride etch.
OK, so what they do here, they
take a typical spatial map,
19 measurements.
The paper says two
concentric hexagons.
But if I look at it, they look
like two concentric octagons,
because it's eight points.
So I don't know
where that came from.
But it's basically these
octagons plus the center point.
There may have been replicates
to get to the 19 measurements.
Not entirely clear.
But then their
process conditions
are temperature, microwave
power, pressure in the chamber,
as well as nitrogen
and hydrogen flows.
So it's sort of
a five factor DOE
that they're going
to be exploring.
And what they note is
that the removal rates
do have a spatial dependence as
a function of these conditions.
Things like gas flow rate
means more of the gas
is coming in contact with the
center or the edge of the wafer
perhaps at different
temperatures, different process
conditions.
So they do have an etch
rate that varies spatially
across the wafer, and they
would like to model that.
Now, what they're going to
do is say if I know my rate
spatially across the
wafer, I am going
to then calculate non-uniformity
as a derived parameter.
I'm not just going to
sum up my data points.
I am actually going to try
to use kind of the model
and do a ratio of standard
deviation to mean.
But it is derived
from the model.
And so their basic idea
is to do this two level
model or two layered
model of the etch rates.
So what they're going to
do is say the etch rate is
a function of both
spatial terms,
sort of the same thing we saw
before, xy, xy, x squared,
y squared.
But also of processed terms.
So what they would like to
be able to do is plug in
and say, OK, if I know
my hydrogen flow rate
and I want to look at some
particular xy location,
I would like to know at
this process condition
and at this spatial location
what is my etch rate.
So what they have
to do is basically
fit this two layered
model that has
both dependencies on the
spatial terms and on the process
terms in it.
And another way of looking
at this is essentially
what they're doing is, as
I mentioned earlier, they
are building a
spatial model where
each coefficient, sort
of an a1, is also then
a function of the
process conditions.
So here's an example
of a regression surface
that comes out.
This is the spatial regression.
Again, as a function of xy
and so on for the removal
rate or etch rate
of silicon nitride.
And then these coefficients
themselves, they go in
and they build a model
of those coefficients
as a function of the process.
And when you do that, you can
get some pretty good fits.
Look at these.
These are square root of in the
range 0.93, 0.90 is the worst,
0.99 for each of the
significance for each of those
terms.
In other words, this
is the spatial model
for that c sub 2n whatever.
C sub 2x.
I guess c sub 2y yn.
But the goodness of
fit, then, of doing
that spatial coordinate model
is a function of the process.
It's a pretty good fit.
And then what they
do is say, OK, I'm
going to do polynomial
regression, as we saw before.
They actually find
kind of a nasty thing.
To get good fits, they
had to go to cubic fits.
That may be.
Just a couple of other
points of interest here.
They use the Latin hypercube
sampling rather than
a central composite sampling.
This is a really
cute sampling plan.
Did I describe this Latin
hypercube sampling plan before?
I think I did.
But basically this
was saying, OK,
if I have a space,
some x1 parameter
and some x2
parameter, and I only
have five data points
I'm going to allow myself
to sample, what you do is
you basically divide both
your coordinates or dimensions
up into five spaces, five
equal spaces.
And then you take a
sample point and make sure
that every one of your
five sample points
uniquely follows in
one row and one column.
So you might get
something like this.
What am I missing?
Maybe that.
And what's cool there
is if you project down
onto either x1
coordinate, now I've
got sort of five data points
spread throughout that space.
Or if I project
down onto the x2,
I similarly have
five coordinates
spread throughout that space.
You have to be a little bit
careful, because that algorithm
could have
accidentally given you
a spatial correlation
in your sampling.
So for example,
those points follow
my rule of one row, one column.
But that has an unintentional
correlation in it.
So there's a part of the
Latin hypercube sampling
algorithm that swaps rows
and columns to avoid that.
So that's what they do there.
Actually, it's good
that you're aware
of Latin hypercube
sampling, because especially
for constrained cases where
you know how many data points
you can sample, it's actually
quite an interesting approach.
OK.
Then what they go in
and do is build out
of these fundamental rate
functions that they fit,
they built derived functions.
These are derived.
It says if I know the
removal rate or etch
rate at different locations,
now I can fold that together
to calculate an
aggregate uniformity
kind of using some
of these ideas
we were talking about before.
I'm not simply calculating from
my raw data uniformity number
and then building a separate
model, a separate response
surface model, a separate
polynomial model of uniformity.
Instead I'm getting close
to the physics as I can
and build this great
model and then recognize
that uniformity is simply
a calculated function
across that underlying
rate function.
And they happen to be
using something like a rate
sigma divided by rate mean.
So they're integrating
that over their space.
By the way, this little
n simply indicates
that they're calculating
separately or building models
separately for the oxide rate
and the nitride etch rate.
They both vary spatially.
So they built these two models.
They do the same thing
for this selectivity.
Again, this is the
ratio of etch rate
of nitride to silicon dioxide.
And that also is
a derived model.
And notice that there's
something really important
about these derived
models and why they help.
May be less obvious,
although we've already
talked about it here with
the uniformity metric.
Maybe they'll focus first
here on the selectivity.
Is selectivity a
linear function?
No.
It's kind of nasty.
It's a ratio of two other rates.
Why would that
necessarily be linear?
This is kind of a
complicated functional form
that if you were trying to
directly model selectivity,
it might be very
difficult to capture
by chance that complicated
functional form.
And even worse, think
about the computations
that go in the calculation
of standard deviation.
Remember standard deviation?
It's the square root of
the sum of some x sub
i minus the mean squared
divided by 1 over n minus 1.
So you got squaring.
You got a square root in there.
That's a very
nonlinear operation.
Why would a linear model be
very good at capturing that?
In fact, if you tried
to do it directly,
you might get a
non-uniformity that
needed not only cubic
terms, but who knows,
fourth order terms, fifth order
terms, which would be quite
complicated to actually fit it.
And what they're showing in
the paper is an example where
a relatively simple
rate function,
they're doing it here also
as a function of, say,
theta and r, not just, say,
xy, but that transformation
is pretty simple.
If you then feed that into
the uniformity calculation,
the expansions of
squares and square roots,
you get kind of
almost, if you will,
for free a functional
form that is
quite complicated in
capturing the true functional
dependencies of uniformity.
That's the important
idea here is you
have a simple, direct,
underlying model of rate.
And then if you've got
a complicated functional
dependence, like
non-uniformity metric on that,
you calculate that from the
simpler underlying model.
I like that.
I think that that's nice.
That's a key idea in this paper.
Then they go on and do, once
they've got these models,
they do multiple
objective optimization
trying to minimize or
maximize selectivity, minimize
their non-uniformity
value, maximize the rate.
They've got some constraints.
They go in and kind of
do a multiple objective.
Come up with some optimum values
and show how much improvement
they get.
But the key idea, I think,
was that contribution
of this notion that you
want to start with something
that's simpler model.
Then if you've got a complicated
optimization objective,
use the simple model, build
the complicated objective
or complicated derived
function, and then use that.
So any questions on that?
Does that seem pretty clear?
What I'm going to show next is
the last piece of this puzzle,
which is--
yes, before I do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's different
to [INAUDIBLE] when you
compare rectangle to circle.
So the circle has the minimal
area to perimeter ratio,
while the rectangle
has the maximum.
So it's most likely when we have
a rectangle we most likely have
to have a uniform sampling.
Is it correct to
look at it that way?
DUANE BONING: I don't
see a relationship
between the perimeter to area.
AUDIENCE: For a given perimeter.
DUANE BONING: And the
reason I'm not sure
that works is if I
have-- here's my wafer.
In the rectangular case, it's
easy to sort of tessellate
the space and cover the space
with non-overlapping regions
that each data point represents.
In order to do that with
the circular sampling plan,
each one of these
is not a circle.
The way you have to sort of
do it is each one of these
is this arc to cover the
space with non-overlapping.
Now, who knows?
If you allow yourself sort
of overlapping coverage,
maybe what you're talking
about makes sense.
But I don't think it's really
a perimeter that each area--
I think it really
is area, just purely
area that it's representing.
But I haven't thought
about the perimeter issue.
It's kind of interesting.
And by the way, this is
the kind of calculation
you would do back
in spatial modeling
to figure out as a
function of your xy
coordinate for your
measurement point
how much area that
ought to represent.
You're basically
dividing it up and you
have to kind of do
those calculations.
OK.
The last thing I want to show
is this paper by Guo and Sachs.
And again, I remind
you Elliot Sachs
is a professor here in
mechanical engineering
who two lives ago
did a lot of work
in semiconductor
process control.
His life after that
was 3D printing.
And his current life
is now solar energy.
So he's made some
wonderful contributions
and some big moves.
And I actually like
this paper quite a lot.
The basic idea in this, it's
looking at this issue, again,
of spatial uniformity, how one
does modeling, and then uses
that for optimization and
control of uniformity.
And basically, here
he builds on, I think,
he builds on this notion that
we learned from the Mozumder
and Loewenstein paper, which is
build simple underlying models
and then combine them and
use them to solve the larger
problems.
But keep it as simple
as you possibly can.
And he suggests,
together with Andy Guo,
he suggests that we
should flip around
what Loewenstein
and Mozumder did
and actually build models for
each spatial location first.
Don't fit the
spatial model first
and then take that
coefficient and try
to build a model
of that coefficient
as a function of process.
Instead just look at
that one spatial location
and build a model of that
spatial location's response
as a function of the
process conditions.
And now I can combine that to
other spatial derived things,
like fitting a spatial model
or not necessarily even fitting
a spatial model, but
now I can basically
use spatial information,
not lose it.
I still know the left
side or the right side
is higher or lower.
What happens when you calculate
standard deviation over mu?
You lose information of
left side or right side
was higher or lower.
You just boil it down
to they were different.
He says keep the sites.
Keep the sites.
Use that information to
drive towards an improvement.
Keep the simple
model, build those,
and then you can combine them.
So let's look and
see how that works.
Here's the basic idea.
Let's say I was measuring
three different locations
on the wafer, y1, y2, y3.
And I have two
equipment settings.
So two different
process parameters.
What you're going to do here
is build a response surface
model and a DOE.
And there's two different
approaches one can take.
One can take what I'll
called the single response
surface, the classical
approach that
says I'm looking at different
combinations of my input
parameters.
I measure my three points.
I've got three data points I can
then calculate for that process
condition, that run number one.
I can calculate the standard
deviation across those three
data points, divide by the mean
of those three data points.
That gives me what the
uniformity spatially
was for that run.
I can then repeat that for
all of my different process
conditions.
And then I can build a
single response surface
at the end, SRS, Single
Response Surface,
that is the response surface of
the response of non-uniformity
as a function of my
process conditions.
That's a classic approach,
and you will still
run into that in many papers.
We didn't see it in
the Loewenstein paper.
They used a slightly
different approach.
But this is a classic approach.
And what he says is
no, don't do that.
Do not do that.
Instead use the same design
of experiments, same data,
but do something that I think
is a little bit smarter, which
says take your different site.
This is a site one.
I'm always measuring
the left side.
Maybe this is the center.
This is the right
side of the wafer.
And build a response surface
for that site response,
maybe it's the thickness or
the etch rate or whatever,
as a function of the
process conditions.
Do the same for all of
the sites that you've got.
Build separate multiple
response surfaces.
And now you know how each site
responds for whatever process
conditions you want.
And now you can combine them
if you want a uniformity
metric to see which is better.
But you can also
do smarter things
like try to balance them.
Get the left side back up
to match the right side.
Do other sorts of things.
OK, let's see how that works.
His basic point here is
very similar to the Mozumder
and Loewenstein, which
is the single response
surface is a very tough
job to directly model
in one response surface, this
highly nonlinear sigma over mu.
And in fact, if I try to
build a second order model,
you often need a
second order model
as a function of the
process conditions,
which means lots of sampling
in your multiple levels
in your process conditions,
at least three, maybe more.
And you get a very
complicated model.
What he also shows
is that very often
with the multiple
response surface model,
you can have much simpler lower
order models for each site.
And in fact, what
he will do is show
if I just build a linear model
for each site as a function
of my process
conditions, meaning I
actually need fewer
levels in my DOE.
I can actually get simple linear
models for my individual sites.
And then when I
functionally calculate
the mu, the mean of those
three, that's a simple formula,
and standard deviation over
mu is a simple formula.
But embedded in it is the
right nonlinear functional form
for sigma over mu.
And so you get this
non-linearity out
of very simple linear models.
And that's the key idea.
Similar to Mozumder
and Loewenstein.
Build the simple
model and then use it
and combine it in whatever
complicated functional form
you have.
So he argues that
you can actually
get a smaller number of data.
Not just use the same data in
a smarter way, but actually
sample less in your process
conditions in many cases.
So you get a savings in the DOE.
Another very nice
advantage that's
articulated in the paper, I'm
not going to go into here,
is that each of those
models of the process
is a nice, simple linear model.
And you can use simple
linear models with the cycle
to cycle run by run control
that Dave Hardt talked
about a couple of lectures ago.
You can basically
take that as a model,
adapt that model rapidly
to changing process drifts
or conditions in your equipment,
use that updated model in sort
of a PI or PID kind
of fashion, and use
that to improve the
selection or pick
the selection of the
right process condition
for the next wafer run.
It's a lot easier to use this
kind of a model for cycle
to cycle control.
He also has some other
very nice points.
He does a bit of analysis in
the paper saying which one
is less susceptible to noise.
It turns out that the site
models kind of average
out noise a little bit better
than putting everything
into signal to noise.
And then the last point is a
really important one, which
is if you get this
really complicated
functional cubic
model that tells you
how non-uniformity changes
as a function of your process
condition, do you as the process
engineer have any idea really
intuitively what will
happen if you change a knob
or what's happening
spatially across your wafer?
His argument is you've lost
a lot of that information.
If you actually have
your site models,
you can build that
full spatial map,
see how each site is changing
as you change your process
condition, and actually see--
build some process
knowledge, see
what's going on much
closer to the process.
So here's a couple of examples.
This relates to,
again, the point
that the complexity of
the uniformity metric
has a lot in it and you
actually lose information.
So here's the point where
if I measure the thickness
at the left site, thickness
at the right site, so red
is my left and blue here are
my right measurement points.
Let's say I have
simple linear responses
for how those two sides change
as a function of the input
parameter.
They really do change linearly.
Notice what happens,
in one case,
the left side is much
thicker than the right
and in the other
process condition,
the right side is much
thicker than the left.
If you actually just directly
do a single response surface
kind of idea or do our
calculation of sigma over mu,
you can easily get a
little bit fooled here.
They're both equal in terms
of a uniformity value,
but you've lost track just
looking at these values
by themselves.
You don't know what's
going on on the wafer.
So looking back
here, you can see
what's going on in the wafer.
The second point is if
one wants to actually go
in and do a medium
input and interpolate
if I have these site
models, I could actually
project and guess
and say, I think
that if I were to
run at the middle,
I would have very
good uniformity.
The thickness would be
the same in both cases.
And if I calculate a value based
on these underlying models,
I can actually
project what happens
at the intermediate values.
This would suggest for a control
problem or an optimization
try the center point.
Whereas if all I had were
these two data points,
I would say they're the same.
I can't really
improve things much.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Left or right
with respect to [INAUDIBLE]
if you have a wafer and you
have a knot and then [INAUDIBLE]
wafer is in a certain way
with respect to the notch,
but you still have a reticle.
And that can be with any
direction with respect
to the notch.
So any information
that you get, you
would never be sure for
the friendships how--
DUANE BONING: Yeah, I'm not
projecting down to chip level.
I'm thinking here wafer level.
And I think you always
know-- you can always
refer to something with the
wafer notch or the wafer flat.
So I think that's--
right and left, these
are conceptual here,
but I think they can
be very well defined.
If you are also worried
about repeated chip scale
things coming from
lithography fields,
that's an extra layer
of spatial concerns.
OK.
And then this is essentially
the implications for control
are pretty much what
I was just describing.
If you just use sort of
the high and the low,
and this is your
intended input, you
can now predict a
little bit better
what your actual output would
be with these simplified cases.
So in the paper,
they do some examples
actually using some experimental
data that they generated.
This was for the low
pressure chemical vapor
deposition of polysilicon.
And it has spatial uniformity
in it not just on the wafer.
Actually what they're doing
here is spatial uniformity
across the tube.
So as a function
of wafer position,
these are big multi-wafer tubes
that might actually process 24
or 48 or 96 wafers all at once.
And there's a gas flow.
There's an injector for
the gas, and the gas flows.
We've got a center
injector, source injector.
The gas flows are
somewhat non-uniform.
And you may, in fact, have
systematic spatial dependencies
as a function of temperatures,
gas flows, and so on.
And what they basically
went in and did
is compared single
response surface models
to multiple response
surface models.
Pictured here is
basically showing
this complicated
dependence of signal
to noise ratio, the single
response surface model,
but the simple dependence
of deposition rates
on these two parameters.
So down here, this is
basically saying my site here
is wafer number 26.
I want to know what the
average thickness on wafer 26
is as a function of
these two flow rates.
And it's a nice, simple
dependence on the flow rates.
If I look at a different
site, a little bit
further down the tube
at wafer number 124,
I also get a simple model.
But if I now combine these
into a sigma over mu,
it has a very complicated shape.
Built out of these simple
dependencies, simple responses
spatially, they combine
to a very complicated
non-uniformity signature.
Then what they did
is say, OK, I'm
going to compare SRS to
MRS. And I'm, furthermore,
going to tie one
arm behind my back
when I do MRS. The arm I'm
going to tie behind my back
is I'm going to let SRS
do three level DOEs.
Two parameters, flow rate
one and flow rate two.
But I'm doing a full
factorial three level.
I do nine different
process experiments.
And I fit the model for
non-uniformity for that.
For MRS, I'm just
going to let myself
pick the high and the low.
I'm just going to do less than
half the number of experiments
and build my site
models and then
see what kind of predicted
signal to noise ratio
I will get.
And I'm going to
look now at also
how noise factors into this and
see, do I do better with SRS
or do I do better with MRS?
And this is a picture that
shows, hey, in these two cases,
they're kind of suggesting
different non-uniformity
signatures.
But what happens
now if I repeat that
with different amounts
of injected noise?
And it's basically
showing that the MRS
in four repeats of
this kind of experiment
with different amounts
of injected noise
pretty much gives the
same surface each time.
Look what happens over
here in the SRS case.
Three out of the
four times, they're
kind of the same bowl shaped.
But one case, you actually get
this weird hyperbolic surface.
More susceptible, this is
just kind of an example
not proving anything, but
just showing an example
that actually the models
you get with the SRS
can actually vary and be
much more sensitive to noise
even though you got
more measurements, more
spatial sample or more
levels of your DOE.
And then they went
in and did sort
of a more thorough example,
building lots of models,
and then using that
model to drive or select
what an optimum point is.
So maybe you were trying to
maximize the removal rate,
find the optimum point
in each of those cases
and see what the spread
is with the SRS and MRS
in the predicted optimal points.
And you can see over
here on the right
the basic conclusion
that they come
to is based on the
single response surface
model and the multiple
response surface model.
They're spread in the two
in terms of the optimum.
But the single response surface
model is basically biased.
It drives you to
an optimum point
that is actually not close
to the measured optimum point
on average.
They basically say single
response surface modeling
is dangerous.
Not only is it
inefficient, but it
can drive you to make errors.
So that's a very
interesting observation.
So I think I'm going to
wrap it up here so we have
a little bit of time to talk
about some of the projects,
especially with Singapore people
while we've got the video.
But I think these are really
neat papers, really neat ideas.
Basically first idea is spatial
sampling, how you sample,
and what area each of
those sampling points
represents matters.
So you can be smart about
that, using either weighting
or uniform sampling.
And then there's some neat
ideas about combined process
and spatial modeling.
I basically really like the
multiple response surface
modeling approach.
I think the Mozumder
and Loewenstein
was a nice stepping
stone on the way
to recognize that you'd
like to build simple models
and then derive on them.
I like the Guo and Sachs because
it carries it one step further.
It says build simple
models of your response
at each of your
spatial locations
and then combine
those or use those
as you see fit to either
boil down and come up
with an overall uniformity or
make other kinds of control
or optimization decisions.
So any questions on that
before we switch over
to talking about some projects?
Think about it.
Maybe some of your
data is actually
a spatially sampled for
one of your projects.
It'd be cool.
Cool to add some spatial
modeling in there.
How finely refined can you
probe that monkey brain?
OK, that's it.
I know some of the
folks here in Cambridge,
I've met with one group.
I think Dave has talked to
Matt and you guys are thinking.
I talked also-- will want
to try to set up a meeting.
I think I sent email
pretty much to everybody
saying I think the
projects look good.
Here's some ideas you
might think about.
The purpose of the meeting
is not to get approval.
Consider this now.
You're approved.
Go, run.
You've only got a week.
Less than a week.
Go full boar.
The purpose of the meeting is
to answer questions, help out
if you've got
additional inquiries.
Feel free to contact me, Dave
Hardt, Hayden, at any time.
But I would like, if we haven't
had a chance to talk yet,
just try to set something up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Well, one and a
half hours less than one week
from today will be the--
so what I will also be
doing is making assignments
for what groups will present
on Tuesday for the next week
and what groups will present
on Thursday of next week.
So it'll be kind of
random luck of the draw.
But I'll let you know
by the end of this week
when your time will be.
And then everybody's
reports are due on Friday
of next week, the end of class.
OK?
I didn't mean to panic you.
You've got almost at least a
full week for the presentation.
And then in fact, one idea is
if you get some quick questions
or feedback from the class, from
us, during the presentation,
it gives you a quick chance
to maybe add a little bit
or do a quick
additional analysis
before the report is due.
So I actually do
recommend that you
take that opportunity
to fold in some feedback
from the presentation.
Do not think that you're
locked in completely
at the presentation.
That's most of the
way there, but it
does give a chance for a
little bit of additional work
in the last couple of days.
OK?
Thanks.
So let's see.
Singapore folks.
First I think I have--
let me get out of this.
Somebody sent me slides.
Let me talk with
that group first.
Yeah.
So David, Stephen, Jenny.
These were the
slides you guys sent.
So somebody want to--
somebody talk me through these.
I can push buttons if you
want or you can come up.
It's probably easier
to do this than try
to switch control to Singapore.
AUDIENCE: OK, so our project try
to apply the [INAUDIBLE] method
to supply chain case study.
So we can click to next slide.
Next slide.
I think we can skip this.
Also this will be
basically the model.
We can consider the
supplier and Company X
and can consider the customers.
So following other parameters
that we will consider,
[INAUDIBLE] service level that
your supplier promised to you
will be the buffer size in the
company between the machines.
And I have TDF and TDR.
And p, the production
rate of the flow line.
LT, the transportation lead
time from company to a customer.
LC is the lead time
that the company
promised to the customer.
And mu and sigma for the demand.
DUANE BONING: So quick question.
Are all of these sort
of input parameters
or are some of these
output parameters?
AUDIENCE: These are the
input parameters I think.
All of these parameters
are the DOE parameters.
DUANE BONING: OK.
So some will be sort of set that
essentially define the setup.
And some will be DOE.
That's what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DUANE BONING: OK, OK.
AUDIENCE: And next slide.
It's about the problem
that is for the company.
Sometimes the service level
will out of the range.
And also using the data
for the service level
is unlike other parameters.
The data is quite less.
So we need to detect the
shift as soon as possible.
And after that, you may want
to improve some parameters
to improve the service level.
So the objective-- yeah.
DUANE BONING: So you've got sort
of two branches here in part.
One is essentially SPC, right?
So that's what you're saying?
And the other is optimization.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's right.
DUANE BONING: OK.
Got it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And you click again.
This objective.
To find the first
step is apply the SPC.
And you find out what
are the main effects
in the second stage that
you apply the RSM to do
optimization to give
advice for the company that
how can you
distribute the budget
to adjust some of the
parameters to get the best
result for improving
the service level.
DUANE BONING: OK.
So one thought here,
just going back.
Let's see.
Back to this slide.
Some of these parameters
might be discrete,
which is interesting, I think.
So it looks like buffer
size is probably discrete.
Is that the plan?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
DUANE BONING: Is that the
only discrete parameter?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
that's the only one.
DUANE BONING: Because that
might be interesting in terms
of the DOE.
Does the discreetness matter?
You have only choice A, B,
C, and it might be hard.
Here it might
still be monotonic,
meaning there really
is a progression.
So you could have
discrete levels,
and they might have
three levels that are
ordered in some meaningful way.
So that'll be an
interesting-- that
might be an interesting twist
both on the DOE, but more
interestingly, for
response surface
modeling and optimization.
Because what do you do
if your optimization
says pick a buffer size of 1.2?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
DUANE BONING: So I think that's
an interesting twist you'll
have to deal with.
So you might actually
have to sort of come up
with some, on that point,
some strategies for rounding
off and maybe assessing both the
high and low round off points
to see which one's
actually better.
That might be an
example strategy.
OK, keep going.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
OK.
That's the three stages
that we summarize.
First stage is the advanced
SPC. The second stage the DOE.
And the last stage is
response of this model.
DUANE BONING: When
you say stage,
does it have to
be in that order?
AUDIENCE: I think yeah.
First because you try
to plot the control
chart for the service level.
Then you find the problem.
Then you start to
focus on the effects.
That's stage two.
And after that you
do the optimization.
That's what we think
should be order.
DUANE BONING: Because one
thought maybe to think about
is whether switching that
order might make sense.
I mean, in one scenario,
I think you're right.
And in one actual sort
of real life scenario,
you may have SPC
charts already up.
And then you go out of control.
You see you're out
of spec somewhere.
And then if I understand
your approach here,
you're saying to figure
out what the problem was,
you want to do a DOE
and solve the problem.
That might be an
interesting scenario,
but often the other way
around is do a DOE up front
so you actually know what
you should be monitoring.
You actually understand larger
the basic relationships,
what's significant, what
you should be monitoring,
where there's a
likely actual effect.
And then help use the
DOE to set up the SPC.
Or maybe the sequence--
maybe what I would do,
maybe it goes the
other way around.
Stage four, revise
SPC. Maybe that
would be a good compromise.
Because I think once
you've built a DOE,
now you've got a lot more
information about what the--
you've got a more solid model,
a more functional model.
And you can use that to perhaps
set better limits on SPC
and decide what parameters
are most important.
So I like that.
AUDIENCE: That's right, we
can revise the control chart
parameters.
Yeah, that's right.
And I think we'll use CellSim.
It's an Excel based
simulation software
to build a model,
supply chain model,
and used Minitab to
follow data analysis.
OK?
DUANE BONING: OK.
Great.
So this is all going to be--
do you actually have
some company data
or are you going to pretty much
mostly use the CellSim model?
AUDIENCE: Next slide.
You can change to next slide.
DUANE BONING: Ah, good, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So for the service
level, I think
we will get from the simulation.
But the input from the company.
Because we can't get the service
level data from the company.
DUANE BONING: OK.
So if I understand
what you're saying
is you might actually try
to model kind of a real line
with some of the parameters
that tell you how that line is
structured and then use that
to do simulations and generate
service level?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's right.
DUANE BONING: I see.
AUDIENCE: So the input
from company, yeah.
DUANE BONING: OK.
But you have no output
data from the company?
It's all going to be simulation?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's right.
DUANE BONING: OK, OK.
That certainly
gives the advantage
I talked about today
of synthetic data.
I mean, it's nice that you've
got a realistic scenario based
on a company scenario for
setting up your simulation.
But you have lots of latitude
in your synthetic data
to actually--
I would encourage you
to consider exploring
intentional perturbations.
You can introduce different
faults into your line
and see what happens both
in the SPC and in the model.
You've got a lot of
flexibility because you're
doing the simulation.
And you can play
with and say what
happens if this piece
of equipment goes down
or the mean time
to failure triples.
And I didn't know that.
How does things improve?
Or mean time to failure
becomes 1/10 what it was.
I'm failing much more often.
So I think you can
construct very nicely
a lot of different scenarios
based on your knowledge
from sort of factory modeling
that might be relevant ones
to study with a DOE approach.
So I think that's rich.
That gives you a
lot of opportunity.
So that's good.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I think that's the
end of the slides.
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
Hayden, do you have--
you want to-- here,
why don't you?
GUEST SPEAKER: We're
just thinking more
about additional things
you might explore.
So let me just make
sure I understand
how the Excel model works.
I mean, it sounds
like you actually
have a function that determines
y as a function of all
these input variables.
And you know what
that function is.
DUANE BONING: Well,
it's very complicated.
GUEST SPEAKER: But
you know what it is.
So if you're doing DOE, you're
trying to build a model,
but you already have the model.
So I'm not sure the timeline.
Basically, you're going to be
trying to get to the model--
AUDIENCE: Actually you don't
have to the exact model.
The service level relates
to all of the parameters.
But you cannot derive a model.
GUEST SPEAKER: You can't derive
a-- so how is this exact model?
Is it a lookup
table or something?
AUDIENCE: We will
simulate the supply chain
and we run the simulation
to get a production lead
time, a production cycle time.
That is influenced by the
buffer size, by the MTTF, MTTR.
And we will check for
the production lead time
plus transportation lead time.
If this is less
than the lead time
that you promised your
customer, then that
means you satisfy the customer.
And if the production lead
time plus the transportation
lead time larger
than LC, then it
will account for
one [INAUDIBLE]..
That's what we generate
the service level.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK, I see.
So you want some approximate
way of predicting
what it's going to be.
OK, fair enough.
DUANE BONING: I
think Hayden's point
is if you have, in
general, very often you
have very complicated
models that
may take a long time to
actually run any one point.
And so I think that's
lurking in your mind.
What you would
like to do is build
simplified approximate
derived models
off of a complicated
long simulation time
sophisticated CellSim model.
Is that right?
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
Great.
DUANE BONING: I mean, even
though CellSim may actually
be fairly fast.
In what I've seen in many of
these factory simulations,
running the factory simulation
itself may take hours or days.
And that's where you
might actually be building
a simplified approximate model.
AUDIENCE: I have
one question here.
I'm not very sure
about the demand data.
But seems like the
CellSim can only
have a normal distribution, an
exponential distribution input.
So if the normal
distribution is not
very appropriate for the
demand, what can we do?
DUANE BONING: Good question.
I think if it can at least do
two different distributions,
one interesting thing would
be to see how sensitive
the simulation is to whether
it's-- you said a normal
distribution and the
other was a Poisson?
Or what was the other one?
AUDIENCE: It's a exponential.
DUANE BONING: Exponential.
I think usually
an exponential is
what's often assumed for these
kinds of arrival processes.
But it would be interesting,
actually, to see how much--
that might end up being
a nice question for you
to ask you and try with your
data and your simulation.
How do things differ as
a function of not just
the parameters of
the distribution
but the type of distribution?
It might not matter at all.
That might be crucial.
That might be the
most important thing.
I don't know.
Good.
Any other questions on this one?
AUDIENCE: No, we're fine.
DUANE BONING: Great.
Go for it.
It sounds interesting.
I like how this integrates
your other classes
and your other learning too.
AUDIENCE: That's the
inspiration from another class.
DUANE BONING: Exactly.
OK.
All right.
So let's see.
I had talked with--
is there-- who wants to go next?
Other people have not sent
slides, but let's see.
Who else have--
I sent email to
I think everybody
kind of late last night or
early morning for you guys.
They're all mixing together.
Who wants to talk about
one of their projects next?
Because we still have about
20 minutes on the video time.
Just talk me through your
written thing and some
of the comments I sent.
How about the-- let's see.
I'm looking at the one
for the iron sole plate.
Who's kind of a
lead person on that?
By the way, I liked
this one, because I
got to go and tour the Phillips
factory when we were there
and see some of these
things being made.
So I'm like, oh, this is cool.
This is great.
AUDIENCE: Well, so actually
one we have sent to you.
The other part we
have in mind is
that the company is going to
run some intermediate points.
But it turns out
to be otherwise.
So what we have is that
it's a five parameter.
So they are trying
to build a prototype.
And they're trying to
find what is the output.
So that's the last one that
actually blow out [INAUDIBLE]..
And then yeah, so what
we have is actually
they actually run a full DOE.
So that's what we have.
DUANE BONING: Is that
data already available?
AUDIENCE: Yes it is.
So then what we
have is a full DOE.
So that's to the power of 5.
So that's 32 runs.
And then each run, there
is three radicates.
DUANE BONING: OK, good.
Yes.
Are all of those parameters
basically continuous
parameters?
I on the diagram you
mentioned different diameters
and heights.
Are all of those
continuous parameters?
Are any of them sort
of discrete choices?
I know they only did
two levels of each.
So in some sense,
they are discrete.
But if you were building
a response surface model,
would you be able to
actually have all of them
be continuous parameters?
Or would there be a
mix of some arrangement
of holes and some diameter
that was continuously varying?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
continuous parameters.
And then I think maybe
some of the inputs
are not so measurable.
So maybe they try to--
since some of the inputs
look at the noise input.
And then they may
use the [INAUDIBLE]
to do the robust design.
And maybe it is
a potential area,
because right now there is
still some problem with the data
connection.
And then we are trying to figure
the problem, all those days.
So actually the full area has
not been exactly designed yet.
So that is one of our problem.
Yeah.
DUANE BONING: OK.
But you think you'll have data?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we
have several data.
But we do ANOVA, and then we
find out that our value is not
exactly so high.
It's just a little
larger than 0.5.
So I think maybe the
data is not complete.
So maybe we need more data.
DUANE BONING: OK.
Well, if you get more
data, that's great.
But it's not just
the r squared, but I
assume your ANOVA does show
some significance to a model?
OK.
Good, good.
Then I think you've
got stuff to work with.
Now, in the email--
AUDIENCE: Professor?
DUANE BONING: Yes?
AUDIENCE: I actually think
that it may not be very
significant from the model.
Yeah, I do think that
it's not that significant.
And I actually
talked to the company
to see why they are not
trying to find more points,
since they are not really
able to find a good fit.
But the response
that I got from them
is that to run the
experiment, they actually
need to build a prototype,
which is very expensive.
And as a result, they are
not planning to run that.
Actually, I thought that
is a good idea maybe
to run a midpoint.
I was not able to convince
the company for doing that.
Yeah, so that's a
problem they're facing.
That's a lack of
data for this study.
So at the same time, we
have also [INAUDIBLE]
exploring some
other alternatives.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
we got is actually--
so in the parent case, it's a
product design optimization.
So then the next one
that we're looking into
is a process optimization.
So in the process
optimization, basically it's
a process line where
there is actually
different sole plates
that are actually
they're produced in a
different period of time.
And then they also
manage it differently.
So that's also like the
[INAUDIBLE] influence.
Like for example,
we are also trying
to see, for example,
whether we can
see there's any correlation
between the defects.
The defects are [INAUDIBLE]
or things like this.
So we're trying
to see whether we
can find correlation between
different layers or even
spatially.
Because it's arranged in
terms of rows and columns,
I think that's five
rows and seven columns.
So in each carrier,
that's 35 units.
So then we thought that probably
we can do a nested variance
analysis on that.
So one aspect I'm
looking into is
because we also have the data
for the different stations.
So one thing that
we can look into
is which station is
the main contributor.
So that's one.
So secondly is between
the shift of the timing.
So for example, every
hour, so an hour and maybe
the different shift,
maybe one shift an hour,
things like this.
So then we can also
do a nested variance
based on the shift timing.
DUANE BONING: Right.
This sounds very interesting.
I don't think we have anybody
else doing a nested variance
kind of analysis.
We have several DOEs.
So in the overall
class, I think this
would be very interesting to
have this different project
you're talking about.
Now, for that one you've
already got the data.
It sounds like it's good.
They have lots of manufacturing
data in that case.
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
There are [INAUDIBLE] data.
But then the person
who ran the data,
they actually are not
so careful to take
note of every parameter.
So then initially
I actually talked
to the company,
the person, I asked
whether we can get all
the data and then we
can combine all
the data together
and then we'll be able to
get a very rich set of data.
We can do all the analysis.
But it seems that the data that
we get is missing in pieces.
For example, they are doing
hypothesis testing kind
of thing.
So basically, they
are doing a p-test.
So it's basically a hypothesis
testing where they actually
check each parameter
to see whether it's
significant or not significant.
And so while they
are doing that,
they do not consider
any other parameters.
So although the process is
controlled by many inputs,
but at any single,
one time, they only
care about a particular
set of a parameter.
So as a result, we are not
able to combine all the data
together as one big cell of
data and do as much analysis
as we would like to have.
But we thought that that would
be an interesting project
to go about.
And at the same
time, I also think
that we are trying to continue
to explore a product thing
and be a process thing.
So as to get a comparison--
because we thought that this
real life situation, we also
like to see, is the point
of view for a product DOE
and process DOE--
how is it different.
Also we understand that
there are some limitations
for the product DOE,
because it pretty
difficult for the
company to run,
to make a new
prototype each time
compared to a process
DOE where they can
change a setting rather easily.
Yeah, so there is a plan.
DUANE BONING: I think this
sounds like a very good plan.
Because I wanted to come
back to the product DOE,
because I think--
so first off, I
think with your team,
you've got a good
team of four people.
So being able to look at both
of these problems is great.
And that includes a case study
and examples of real life
limitations that are
there in both situations
and recommendations you
could make in both cases
to the company that might
help them get more value out
of the activities that they've
got to be able to make better
decisions in the future.
So going back to the product
one with the DOE, the two
to the fifth DOE,
I think it would
be very interesting to
somehow include, maybe
you just make it up, but
include what more you could
do if you had a center point.
And show if the center
point looks like this,
look how different
your decision would
be in design optimization.
Versus if your center
point looks like this,
then the model looks
completely different,
and this is what you should do.
In other words, show how
important that center point
might be to their thinking.
Could be a nice part of this
that actually might help
make the case persuasively
to the company
that in their future it
might be very valuable
and worth the expense of
building just one more
prototype.
If they're already building
32 different prototypes
with some missing
data perhaps, one more
would tell them so
much more potentially.
So I think that could
be very interesting.
And I'm glad, I like the plan
of trying to do some of both.
Do I have that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I actually think that when
they made the prototype, maybe
they choose the high and low
because it's easier for them
to make the prototype rather
than making a center point.
So I do understand
that a center point
has the advantage
of being able to fit
models and things like that.
In the technical
aspect, maybe they
are limited by machines
or things like these.
Maybe they have a template
where using a template they
are able to get a
plus or a minus.
But they are not able
to get the midpoint.
So I'm not sure--
perhaps, is it possible that
we discuss points like this?
DUANE BONING: Yes.
Absolutely.
Those are very
realistic limitations.
You might find that a
couple of parameters
can have center points.
Other ones can't.
And so it's a
mixed center point.
And so that's a good issue.
Absolutely.
All of these kind of realistic
constraints that drive--
that help limit or drive
them to the decisions
that they made
but also exploring
is there some room
to do some more?
So yes, that's a
very good point.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
DUANE BONING: Good.
Well, this sounds exciting.
Get the data as
quickly as you can
even with all of its ugliness
and get going on that.
And then if issues
come up, send us email
and we can see what
we can do to help.
So I think I just have a
short period of time now.
Let's see.
I saw you in the
back while the camera
was focused there, Priyanka,
I saw you in the back there.
So you guys project.
[INAUDIBLE] Stanley.
Thoughts on your project?
First off, I really
like the ECM aspect,
because I've got
a student working
on electropolishing
or electrochemical
mechanical polishing
for semiconductor stuff.
So the student has been
learning a little bit
about electrochemistry.
So I saw this and I thought
it was really interesting.
AUDIENCE: The story
is sad but true.
It actually happened in
my undergrad university.
And I got rescued on a boat, and
we went to rescue the machine,
and it was bolted
on a concrete slab
and it was under
10 feet of water.
DUANE BONING: Do
you have pictures?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I do.
DUANE BONING: Oh good.
Excellent.
Now, in terms of--
I think I sent a little bit of
information back in the email,
because it looked like,
if I'm remembering,
you wanted to do
a couple of things
to see was the
equipment restored
and operating back to
its original state.
And I understood--
AUDIENCE: That's correct.
DUANE BONING: Yeah, I
understood that part.
And then the other
interesting piece
was building an analytic model.
And using that,
it sounded like--
well, tell me what
you would like
to do with the analytic model.
AUDIENCE: So initially,
the experiment
was done to get
data to substantiate
an analytical model.
So the model was based on the
Faraday's laws of electrolysis.
But that related only a
few of the parameters.
So we were basically trying
to incorporate the flow rate
term into that equation.
But the focus kind of got
shifted because the machine
stopped running midway.
And we spent a very
long time trying
to get it back on its feet.
And the readings that
we took after that,
so I can sort the readings
on the basis of date.
We were four students
working on that project,
and we took a large
set of readings.
So I can sort it by
date and find out
what's before the flood
and what's after the flood
and to find out if really a
shift had occurred after that.
When we were using it,
we never treated it
as a separate set of data.
We combined and indiscriminately
averaged out the whole thing.
So that's something that
in hindsight we probably
should have looked at.
DUANE BONING: OK.
I think that's sort of the core
of the idea for your group.
And I like that.
What I'm thinking about
is if there's one or two
additional ideas
that you might be
able to explore given
the fact that you've also
got this analytic model.
So it's going back a little bit
to this idea of synthetic data
or looking at your
analytic model
and maybe even doing
things like a sensitivity
analysis on the model.
Saying based on the
model, these are
the parameters I think we would
be most sensitive to in a DOE.
Some of those kinds of things.
I think it might be neat
to just brainstorm or think
about things you might actually
use the analytic model,
since you've got that also.
Even though you only know some
constants from physics and some
you were trying to
fit to your data.
And that whole piece
sounds very interesting.
AUDIENCE: OK.
The data we have basically
consists of varying three input
parameters.
Feed rate, flow
rate, and voltage.
And the output is the MRR.
So the way we
measured MRR was we
took the difference in
the weight of the slab.
DUANE BONING: Yes,
that sounds good.
AUDIENCE: And the time
for the machining.
And so we have the MRR for
about-- we have about 50 to 60
readings that we've taken.
DUANE BONING: Good.
Yeah, that was my other question
in the email was how much data
you had.
Because it sounded like
each run is fairly long.
Yeah, so you've got
lots of students working
on this for a long time.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we have
four students working on it
almost around the clock.
So quite a lot of readings.
DUANE BONING: OK, that
sounds very interesting.
And it will be an interesting
story to hear as well.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'll try
to put in some pictures.
DUANE BONING: So if
other questions come up,
let me know, especially as
you think a little bit about--
your group thinks of ways
to use the analytic model.
OK.
AUDIENCE: A problem with the
data is that the flow rate,
we couldn't vary the flow
rate on digital control.
So there's this whole
set of six valves
that we had to
manipulate to set a flow.
And so all the other factors
are set at fixed levels.
But the flow rate is
kind of an average value
that it kind of
oscillated about.
So I'm not very
sure how to deal.
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
Well first off, that's
an interesting question
we haven't talked a
lot about in class.
So it'll be interesting to
raise that and talk about it.
That basically, there's
a spread on your input.
There's variation on your input.
And some of the methods
we've talked about
might include just recognizing
that and recognizing
that that might propagate
through the data.
Because often we pretend
in all of our DOEs
that when I pick the
input, it's rock solid
and it's never rock solid.
Usually it's very well,
tightly controlled.
But often there is
variation in that.
And the basic approach,
that might be a place where
looking at your analytic
model might actually
give you a sense of
how big a perturbation
variations on the input
might produce in the output.
So you could actually get
an estimate of roughly
how important it is to control
more accurately to the inputs.
Things like that.
So I think that's a very
interesting real life problem.
And that's just one suggestion.
AUDIENCE: There's another issue.
The flow rate was the cause of
all our troubles throughout.
Because we couldn't find a
proper correlation analytically
for the flow rate,
because the voltage
and the other parameters
could be easily incorporated
into the analytic
model just using
an extension of Faraday's laws.
But the flow rate was a
little difficult to capture.
DUANE BONING: So it's
not in the model.
AUDIENCE: It's not
really in the model.
DUANE BONING: I see.
OK.
AUDIENCE: And the way
we calculated flow rate,
the way we've measured
our flow rate is
we've got a maximum value,
a minimum value, and a most
common central value.
That's the way we've
measured the flow rate.
DUANE BONING: I think
it'll be interesting to see
how you dealt with
that or recommendations
on how to deal with that.
That's good.
I think these real life
challenges are a good thing.
Thanks.
I think that one sounds good.
Now let's see.
I'm trying to see.
Have we covered
all the projects?
Or I've left
somebody out, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
I actually have to run.
Let me see.
Which one are you?
AUDIENCE: We're the team working
on the injection molding data.
DUANE BONING: Ah, yes, OK.
AUDIENCE: Die casting, sorry.
We're working on
die casting process.
And we got our
data from a paper.
DUANE BONING: Ah, yes.
So we had some
good email on that.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
I think you guys are
in very good shape.
There were some
suggestions from Hayden.
And I sent an email also.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
DUANE BONING: So did you
have follow on questions?
I think you guys--
that's good data and you
can do a lot more with it.
So any additional
thoughts or questions?
AUDIENCE: So we have a
question concerning inputs.
There are three inputs.
Two of them they
have three levels.
And the other one
has only two levels.
Does it matter when you do--
when you do the ANOVA,
ISM, all these analysis?
Because the levels are
different for inputs.
DUANE BONING: The
quick answer is no.
But it should be interesting
for you to show why that still
is good and that's no problem.
Just think about it.
I mean, in terms of
some model dependencies,
if you have three
levels, you might
be able to do quadratic
in that model parameter.
But if you only have
two levels in others,
you'll only have
linear terms for that.
So that's fine.
That's OK.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DUANE BONING: OK.
So if questions come up as
you're working on that one,
send us more email.
Because Hayden
had lots of ideas.
There may be more
than you can do.
But I think there are some
very interesting ideas,
because there's replicate data.
Variance might be
interesting to model.
Several neat things
you can do with that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
We'll follow with emails.
DUANE BONING: OK.
Good.
And we can also again
on Thursday if there's
more questions that come up.
After class we can talk briefly.
Because by then you
should hopefully
be well into the project.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DUANE BONING: Thank you.
See you guys later.